i just want you to know that the people
of the united kingdom support the people
of ukraine and support you in your fight
and i am absolutely convinced
that you can win and that you will win
thank you very much jacqueline and slavo
so once our friendly force is in
position
to move forward i'll get you a grenade
i've been meeting some of the 400
ukrainian troops who are here uh being
being trained by uh our forces getting
ready to go and uh fighting ukraine
that's part of a huge commitment we've
made to train ukrainian forces
we want to train about 10 000 of them
over the next four months that comes on
top of the uh investment we're making in
uh supporting ukrainians with uh with
weaponry 6900 anti-tank weapons 120
armored vehicles and and much much else
besides including now the multiple
launch rocket systems uh that together
the americans germans and others we're
providing really are starting uh to make
a difference we hope to the course of
that war it's abundant
[Applause]